hi after impressing the judges during
auditions with their original song break
the bank
the young ladies of g-force made it past
a judge's cuts that saw them move
forward to the live show but not without
some constructive criticism from fellow
Canadian how we mend out horrible you
the dancers you're good singers but if
I've got to be totally honest with you I
couldn't hear a word all I heard was
Simon Says
and jump we have been taking Howie's
notes you know we're working on our
enunciation and our diction we just had
to work super hard and train train train
it seems their hard work has paid off
for the group opening the show while
impressing their toughest critic
[Music]
you guys had so much energy I'm feeling
the g-force I'm filled with girl power
it is so weird for middle-aged bald man
we've been getting old tons of nice
comments not just from Canadian people
but from people around the world and it
which is really cool so incredible to
have people you know say that they like
our music and you know they supporting
us and liking our music so it's just so
odd makes us feel really special here